in the film industry a single film can
make or break a career this has been the
case since the dawn of hollywood the
2008 vampire romance movie twilight set
its leads up for stardom based on a
best-selling book series with a built-in
eager fan base the twilight saga
resulted in five films and was a pop
culture phenomenon at the time but not
every star of the franchise reaped the
long-term rewards while two of the leads
kristen stewart and robert pattinson
have been able to find critical and
commercial success following the end of
the twilight franchise the series
thirdly taylor lautner has not been as
fortunate this is actually kind of a
surprise seeing as the actor's role as
the parentally shirtless werewolf jacob
black looked like a pretty safe pass to
stardom and lautner was perfectly
convincing in the role as convincing as
anyone could be playing a smoldering
young jacked wolf man so you're a
werewolf
yeah
last time i checked nevertheless lautner
who played jacob across all five films
has failed to turn his twilight exposure
to a-list stardom while pattinson and
stewart have both managed to star in a
healthy mix of mainstream hits and
critical darlings in fact since the
release of the twilight saga breaking
dawn part 2 in 2012 lautner's
appearances in movies or television has
been noticeably more limited than you
might assume however this relatively
unimpressive trajectory hasn't
necessarily been loutner's own fault in
fact one might argue that his dwindling
career can be traced back to a single
film an action thriller that
single-handedly ruined taylor lautner's
career that doesn't look like me to be
perfectly honest loudner is no stranger
to movies that got a poor critical
reception the twilight movies weren't
beloved by critics and his first
starring vehicle the adventures of
sharkboy and lava girl was disliked by
both critics and audiences the 2010
ensemble comedy valentine's day which to
be fair he only appeared in relatively
briefly has a rotten tomato score of 18
and felicia what is it about willie that
it's so cool
oh well besides the fact that he's
totally hot however if you're looking to
pinpoint a particular film that took a
heavy toll on lautner's career prospects
his 2011 starring vehicle abduction
ended up with a rotten tomato score in
the dreaded single digits a measly five
percent the film's box office results
weren't very encouraging either as the
film grows just over 28 million dollars
domestically on a 35 million dollar
budget relying on its international box
office totals to turn a profit this
might not have reflected too well on
lautner as a bankable leading man seen
as abduction was the first starring role
he did after the initial success of
twilight this was his opportunity to
show hollywood he had what it took to be
an action hero and a dramatic lead
abduction not connecting with audiences
or critics seemed to signal that loutner
would be unable to carry the franchise's
success onto other projects and his
acting cv since then makes it fairly
clear that productions have been
somewhat wary of casting him in leading
roles ever since loudner's last movie
role to date came in the 2016 film run
the tide
are you serious
though abduction certainly didn't do any
favors for taylor lautner's action chops
that doesn't necessarily mean that his
days as an actor are over just look at
is the twilight saga co-star robert
pattinson who spent many post-twilight
years gravitating toward relatively
obscure and creepy dramas and arthouse
films and has only recently started
returning to comparatively mainstream
fair like christopher nolan's tenant and
matt reeves upcoming the batman while
pat and sin went artsy lautner has been
quietly reinventing himself as a bit of
a comedian
he played dr cassidy cascade in the
second season of scream queens a series
with plenty of funny moments and he
replaced none other than andy samberg as
the central character of the tv show
cuckoo after season one cause i can do
this you can do what this
right here maybe i'm already doing it i
don't know in 2015 the twilight star had
a prominent role in adam sandler's
comedy western the ridiculous six go
dang according to imdb lautner is
currently filming home team which is
produced by sandler's happy madison
productions like the ridiculous six the
movie is scheduled to debut directly on
netflix
apart from the occasional comedic role
loudner has recently kept himself busy
with real estate deals as he bought a
luxurious mansion in agora hills
california in 2020 so even though he
might not be the first person hollywood
calls for action movies these days
taylor lautner seems to be living his
best life and keeps himself occupied
with fun projects that have very little
to do with his days as a hunky werewolf
and if you're curious about revisiting
those days the five twilight films are
currently all available to view on
netflix
thank you
no problem
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one